تسهيلا لعمليه التقاضي والترافع التي
يحتاجها الوافدون في السعوديه قام مركز
الترجمه الموحد في وزاره العدل السعوديه
بترجمه نحو اثنين او اثنين 52000 جلسه
خلال العام الماضي يقدم المركز الترجمه
لناطقين بسبع واربعين لغه غدا الفهد
والتفاصيل
قضائيه تمكن مركز ترجمته الموحد في وزاره
العدل السعوديه من ترجمتها خلال العام
الماضي حيث اتاح المركز للمستفيدين
التقاضي بالصوت والصوره عبر نظام
الاليكترونيه عن بعد بمختلف اللغات
وبسريه تامه مبادره انشاء مركز
برنامج التحول الوطني والتي تعمل وتساهم
في تحقيق العداله الناجزه للمستفيدين
الخارجين بالاضافه للضمانات القضائيه
وتسريع نسبه الانجاز القضايا الخاصه
باطراف الدعوه الى التقيم باللغه العربيه
يمكن المركز غير الناطقين باللغه العربيه
من متابعه قضاياهم من خلال مترجمين
يتحدثون سبع واربعين لغه من مختلف لغه
العالم ويربط المركز بين قاعات المحاكم
والسجون وفقا انظمه تقنيه دقيقه
اللغه الانجليزيه والصينيه والا قرانيه
والاكثر طلبا اللغه الارديه تقديم الطلبات
هي بشكل يسير والصير بسيط وسهل ويتم من
خلال منصه تقاضي ترجمه ينشا الطلب اولا من
خلال صحيفه الدعوه في ناجز ثم ياتي الى
تحيه الدعوه ثم لتدقيق الدعوه وانتشر الى
الذهاب الى
الدائره القضائيه
القانونيه الشائعه في المحاكم السعوديه
ابرز الاسس التي يتم تدريب المترجمين
عليها لضمان خدمه افضل للمتقاضين من كل
الجنسيات واللغه غاده الفهد العربيه الريق